- Don't you just wish, though?
Don't you just wish in
your heart of hearts
some terry would come up in here
trying some grab ass
and the touchy feely?
- That's the opposite
of what I want
to have happen on a plane.
- Okay, that's unfortunate.
(rhythmic jazzy music)
(traditional Middle
Eastern music)
- Brothers, brothers
let us begin.
I have convened this meeting
to find out what you are doing.
Why have we not taken
a plane in 13 years?
- Khalid, you don't even know.
It is all because the cunning
and mighty TSA is always
one step ahead of us.
- I do not believe it!
- It's true!
Last month I attempted
to take down a plane
with a pair of scissors
five inches long.
- That sounds like
a perfect plan!
Well, why did it not work?
- Because the shrewd TSA,
they made restrictions
so you can only take
a four-inch scissors.
Four inches.
- What?
- Yes.
- How could they know
that the five-inch blade
is a dangerous weapon
and a four-inch blade is no
more than a child's plaything?
- That is the genius of TSA!
They foil us at every turn.
- Devils!
- You know, it's the
same way with the liquid.
- What about the liquid?
- Yeah, we all know how much
devastation we can wreak
with 3.5 ounces of liquid.
- The damage is incalculable!
- The crafty TSA, they
have limited passengers
to only 3.4 ounces!
- Damn it!
Do none of you have
a solution how,
for us to thwart this TSA?
- Khalid, Khalid, it's like
you've been living in a,
well, here, look.
The TSA, they strike
fear into my heart
with their polyester shirts
and their disposable
rubber gloves,
and the, the sneaker shoes!
- They are so clever.
- [Terrorist] Clever.
- Yes, they act as
if they are listless,
overweight employees who
don't give a (bleep),
when in reality they
are an elite force
of antiterrorist commandos!
- Oh, curse the brilliant TSA!
- Khalid, if I may.
I think I have a way to
triumph over the wily TSA.
- [Khalid] Finally.
(terrorists murmuring)
- [Terrorist 2] Let's
give him a shot.
- I have a plan to put
a bomb in a laptop,
and it will detonate once
you pull it from its case.
(laughs)
- Yes, yes it is perfect!
Planes will rain down from
the sky onto the infidels!
(Khalid sings words of praise)
What, what, what?
- Sneak in here for a second.
I don't want to be the
bearer of bad news-
- [Khalid] Then don't be.
- Maybe you are.
- It's as if the prophetic
and all-knowing TSA
has predicted your plan.
They make you take the laptop
out of the carrying case
and put in a separate bin
before you get on the plane.
- Come on, you've
got to be kidding me.
You've got to be kidding me.
Are you kidding me, Marwaz?
This is not a funny joke
if it's a joke.
- It's no time for kidding.
I wouldn't kid.
- Oh my God.
I can't believe these
mothers of devils.
Well, very well then.
Since you have all
failed, I will tell you
how we will destroy
the nonbelievers.
I have developed the
smallest bomb possible.
And, it fits
perfectly into this.
A full-sized tube of
toothpaste. (laughs)
Yes, it's really
great, isn't it?
I mean, it's literally
a fantastic...
(terrorists murmuring)
What's going on over here?
What's the situation over here?
- Okay.
Is there a version of
the toothpaste bomb
that comes in travel size?
- You know what, it's
like they're in our heads.
(dramatic music)
- [Interrogator] Look, Rajid,
I'm gonna make this really
nice and easy for you.
I need names, and you're
gonna give em to me.
- You have to listen to me.
You have to listen to me.
This is all a huge mistake.
- Bull (bleep)!
Department of Homeland
Security's been
monitoring your calls
for weeks, Rajid.
We got you.
We know about you
and your friends.
We know that you're a-
- Terrier-ist!
I am a terrier-ist.
We, me and my friends,
we breed dogs,
specifically terriers.
We write terrier-ist fiction.
We, we spend a good
deal of time discussing
possible future
terrier-ist plots-
(Rajid grunts)
- It's a nice try, really is.
But it's bull (bleep), Rajid.
Come on, is that
the best you got?
Now come on, I'm listening.
Just tell me, tell me.
Tell me about this
imminent attack.
- What, what?
What attack, I don't know
what you're talking about.
- What am I talking about?
- I don't...
- Huh, I don't know what
you're talking about.
What am I, no, yeah.
You don't know?
- That's what I'm telling you.
I don't know, I don't know.
- June 11th, Rajid!
You spoke of an imminent attack.
- Oh, oh, that was my friend!
Listen, his dog bit him.
- No.
- And I told him,
if you do not train them,
another terrier
attack is imminent.
(Rajid groans and chokes)
- [Interrogator] So you lied,
and you see what happens?
- I'm not lying to you.
- Come on, Rajid, I like you.
Let's be friends, huh?
Now you still haven't
explained to me
why we found, on the search
engine of your computer,
the words "target
Washington" 49 times.
- That is because I was
in DC for a dog show,
and I had to buy a squeezy
toy, a birthday card,
and some deodorant, all
at an affordable price.
- All right.
- You can only do
that at Target.
- Yeah, okay, I see how
you wanna play this.
Come on, gimme this.
(Rajid groans)
This is not a case of
mistaken identity, Rajid,
and you know it!
We've heard the conversations
between you and Jafar
where you're discussing your
hatred of American ideals.
- Idols, American Idols!
I hate them!
They performed "Dancing Queen!"
It was a desecration to ABBA!
My faith in that.
- We got you on tape
referring to Jafar
as one of the architects of-
- [Rajid] 7-11!
It was 7-11.
Jafar, he designs
convenience stores!
- 7-11, oh (bleep).
- Wilson, 65 dogs just
attacked the Capitol Building!
- Were they terriers?
- How did you know?
- (bleep)
- [Rajid] Praise ABBA!
(traditional Middle
Eastern music)
- Okay, there is your gyro.
Here's your burger,
sir, thank you.
And sir, if you could
just wait for one moment.
We are very, very busy
today, I'm so sorry!
- Another great day of
business, Brother Ibrahim!
- Are you kidding me?
Look, we are raking
in the money!
- Praise Allah, I know!
I have just bought a
flat-screen television.
- Really?
- High definition.
- We should watch some
of the American football
on the screen.
- Come, come!
I have the La-Z-Boy.
I have the La-Z-Boy sofa.
- Oh my god, we could have-
- As-salaam 'alykum.
(dramatic music)
Brother Ibrahim, Brother Asman.
- Wa 'alaykum as-salaam,
Brother Mustafa.
- What are you doing here
in the United States?
- A joyous surprise!
- Yes, absolutely!
- I was just checking
on your progress.
- Of course.
- This is a very good front
for your sleeper cell.
The Americans will
never see it coming.
- They are totally
fooled, Brother Mustafa.
They think that we're
just two immigrants
who are in love with the
amazing amounts of money
that you can make
being entrepreneurs.
I mean, this food truck is
like just printing money.
It's a little crazy,
to be honest with you.
It's like a bottomless
pit of money.
You can just reach in,
pull it out, and you-
- When in reality,
Brother Ibrahim-
- Yes, well in reality
we want to destroy
as many of the imperious
infidels as possible.
- Right.
But what I don't understand is,
you have your target,
you have your explosives.
Why not just put the
bomb on the truck
and then drive it straight
into the building,
killing as many
infidels as you can?
- No, so the thing is...
- That we're already doing it.
- How is that possible?
- You see, Brother Mustafa,
these sandwiches are
loaded with cholesterol.
Slowly the infidels,
they grow fat,
and their arteries
start to clog.
- Stop it!
I'm beginning to doubt your
dedication to the cause.
- No, no, no-
- [Customer] Hey guy, can I
just order a fusion burger?
I'm in a hurry.
- Yes, $9 please.
(foreboding music)
- Our leader would
be very displeased.
Did you say $9 for one?
- Yes, yes, and-
- $1 extra for crazy
rockin' hummus.
- How much do they cost to make?
- $1.50?
- $1.50.
- Pretty good margins.
- Yes.
- Yes, yes.
- How many do you sell a day?
- I don't know.
- Maybe a hundred?
- A hundred?
- Yes, sometimes two.
- On a good day?
Maybe two?
- What?
- 200 is a big day.
- But you are
ignoring your mission!
(dramatic music)
You will pay the ultimate price!
- [Asman] No, no, we are still-
(dramatic music)
- Okay, that sounds good.
Your order will be right up.
That'll be $9, please.
- My friends, you must
try Mustafa Kebab!
Only $5!
And one rock and roll
baba ghanoush, $1 extra!
Come on!
- No, no, no, wait-
- Your fusion burger?
- Yo, hey yo.
- Sorry.
- Yo.
Hey yo.
Oh, yo.
Yo, yo.
- Excuse me?
- Oh man, oh man, oh man.
I tell you one thing,
if 9/11 were to happen
up on this here
plane, don't worry.
We got this.
- Okay, I have no idea
what you're talking about.
- He said that if them
terries is gonna try something
up in here today like the
bounce, boogie, and bump,
that we got this
(bleep) on lock.
- Do you mean terrorists?
- Hell yeah, baby.
He ain't talking
about Teri Garr.
- And I certainly ain't
talking about no terrycloth.
I mean, if a terry
up on this plane,
he best thinkin' about
trying to do something,
we gonna wax him up.
- You're, you're gonna what?
- We're gonna draxx
them sklounst.
- I think what my
partner's trying to say
is if any terries
come up in here,
we gonna get our Bergeron.
- Yeah.
- Did something happen,
or did I miss something?
Is this hypothetical or...
- Oh we gonna definitely
drop some hypotheticals
on that terry's clavicle,
'cause I'm talking about pssh.
Squeets, squeets,
squeets, squeets.
Skeet, skeet, skeet, skeet.
- Don't you just wish, though?
Don't you just wish in
your heart of hearts
some terry would come up in here
trying some grab ass
and the touchy feely?
- That's, that's the
opposite of what I want
to have happen on a plane.
- Okay, that's unfortunate.
Conference.
- [Passenger 1]
This was unexpected.
- It certainly was.
I'm thrown right now as to
who's gonna be our comrade.
- I can still hear you.
- [Passenger 2] He doesn't have
the heart nor the gumption.
- You're literally
right next to me.
- On three, break.
Three.
- Yoo hoo, I got an idea.
Feel free to say no.
But can we switch seats?
I will not take
no for an answer.
- Why?
- That's the combat seat,
Johnathan Livingston Seagull.
If you gonna be in
the combat seat,
then you gots to be willing
to blast up on some terries.
Because with great power comes
great responsitriligence.
- Okay, I just, I just
wanted some leg room.
- Okay, Max Legroom,
you get yours.
Meanwhile I'm a go Hayden
Panettiere on some terries,
especially when they get froggy.
- Ribbit, ribbit.
- Um.
- You gonna have to be
ready to kidnap a terry.
- I don't...
- You gonna have to be
ready to torture a terry.
- I don't think
that's necessary.
- Absolutely, you have to
fireboard those mother jammers.
- I don't even understand
what that means.
- Do you trust me?
- No.
- I'll take that as a yes.
- Okay.
- Trust.
These terries come up in
here, trying to act froggy.
- Then we gonna give them
the Rainbow Connection.
Here, froggy, froggy,
froggy, froggy.
- Is that a box cutter?
- Oh, you best believe it, baby.
We gonna be eatin'
like Diane Keaton.
2.36 inches, baby.
- Shwacks.
- Perfectly leg-well.
- And if those don't work?
(gun cocks)
You know I'm workin' up
that Plan B, brother.
- You have a gun?
- Hell yeah, 3D printer, baby.
100% polyurethane.
They can't detect
these mammerjammers.
- They have a weapon,
they have a weapon!
These guys got a weapon!
- Where you at, terry?
(passengers screaming)
- Everybody relax, we taking
control of this plane!
(shouting and yelling)
- We got out the
way, it's really on!
- I'm on vacation!
(kitschy upbeat music)
- Draxx them sklounst.
(upbeat, rhythmic music)
♪ I want you ♪
♪ But I know me ♪